hablemos ahora economía en france 24
para ello ya me acompaña el estudio
daniela blandón daniela buena noche
bienvenida a costa rica entró
oficialmente a la ocde hola raúl buenas
noches mire la organización para el
desarrollo económico de la cooperación y
el desarrollo económico es con la
sociedad popularmente como el club de
países ricos y pertenecer a ella es una
especie de certificado de que el país
tiene los mejores estándares tanto
políticos como económicos sus ahora 38
miembros representan el 80 por ciento
del comercio mundial costa rica es el
cuarto latinoamericano en ingresar
después de méxico chile y colombia
mientras que brasil argentina y perú
todavía son candidatos
nuestra corresponsal cindy regidor nos
contó más más temprano
tres administraciones de gobierno
llevaron a cabo durante once años las
gestiones que culminaron este 25 de mayo
para que costa rica forme parte de la
organización para la cooperación y
desarrollo económicos el proceso empezó
desde 2010 y en 2015 se impulsó una hoja
de ruta para la adhesión del país según
el gobierno de este proceso incluyó
varias reformas como un rediseño del
sistema nacional de estadísticas un
cambio integral de la política de
competencia así como cambios en el campo
de la lucha contra la corrupción manejo
de residuos buen gobierno y
fortalecimiento del sistema financiero
la incorporación de costa rica a la ocde
le permitirá participar en más de 300
comités y grupos de trabajo para
aprender de las experiencias de otros
países e influir en las discusiones
globales de temas trascendentales como
fiscalidad cambio climático y la
educación del futuro la ciudadanía verá
el beneficio del acompañamiento de la
ocde en la calidad de la gestión pública
que mejoraría gracias a las
recomendaciones basadas en evidencia y
según las mejores prácticas
internacionales
nuestra corresponsal sin ti regidor en
costa rica daniel el fondo monetario
internacional destacó el manejo
económico de uruguay durante la pandemia
kabul este organismo hizo una misión que
acaba de concluir de una semana en la
que tuvo reuniones virtuales con
autoridades de ese país para analizar
cómo ha sido la gestión económica
durante la crisis del coronavirus la
conclusión es que gracias a que ésta fue
eficaz el virus tuvo una baja incidencia
durante buena parte del 2020 y permitió
evitar confinamientos generalizados de
esta manera limitó el impacto sobre la
actividad económica
el informe del fm y destaca que hay un
elevado ingreso per cápita con índices
relativamente bajos de pobreza
desigualdad e informalidad pero también
raúl hubo espacio para la crítica el
organismo cree que antes de la pandemia
había ciertos desequilibrios económicos
en este país por ejemplo una escasa
inversión y cierta falta de
competitividad la inflación también es
alta y la desdolarización sigue siendo
una tarea pendiente así de niell a
polonia
pública checas se enfrentan por el
carbón las autoridades de ambos países
iniciaron conversaciones para tratar de
resolver una disputa de hace años en una
zona que se llama turow al sudeste de
polonia y cerca de las fronteras checas
y alemana hay una mina de lignito que es
una especie de carbón mineral república
checa- dice que ha causado graves daños
ambientales como por ejemplo que les
está quitando agua subterránea a sus
comunidades cercanas para gas llevó el
caso a un tribunal de la unión europea
de la que ambos son miembros este él
ordenó a varsovia serra cesar de
inmediato la extracción hasta que haya
una decisión definitiva pero polonia
dice que no puede hacerlo alega que esta
mina alimenta una planta de energía que
abastece al 7 por ciento de su población
de todas maneras el carbón se ha vuelto
un punto de fricción entre los países
del bloque que aspiran a eliminar las
emisiones de aquí al 2050 también
indicadores wall street del cerro con
ligeras pérdidas a medida que el mercado
sigue mostrando mucha preocupación por
la inflación las bolsas europeas
con planas con alemania a la cabeza que
alcanzó a registrar el récord histórico
en la jornada tiene américa latina la
bolsa mexicana cayó por segundo día
consecutivo para finalizar que nos trae
como cifra el día
raúl 2500 son millones de dólares que
fue el superávit comercial en méxico en
abril es lo que quiere decir que las
exportaciones de más de 40 mil millones
de dólares fueron levemente superiores a
las importaciones algo que no ocurre en
toda américa latina así es daniela pues
muchísimas gracias entonces por toda la
información económica como siempre a
ustedes también muchísimas gracias por
siempre estar ahí conectados con
nosotros en nuestra pantalla de france
24 que desee porque hay mucho más para
ver a que nuestro canal
[Música]